when it comes to making a movie
cooperation is key but anyone who's ever
had an annoying co-worker knows that
sometimes you just can't get along with
that jerk you're stuck with considering
how poorly sex in the city ii was
received it's a little surprising there
were any expectations for a third
installment but star Sarah Jessica
Parker said she was disappointed in
September 2017 upon the announcement
that Sex in the City 3 wouldn't move
forward unnamed sources told people that
this was Kim Cattrall's doing claiming
that the star was making outrageous
demands in order to agree to appear in
the third film cotrol however denied the
claims telling Piers Morgan in 2017 I
never asked for any money I never asked
for any projects I'm you know to be
thought of as some kind of diva is
absolutely ridiculous
the New York Post Paula Froelich wrote
an article blaming Parker and the other
co-stars for mistreating cotrol from the
beginning of the HBO series isolating
her early on because they were
intimidated and jealous of arguably the
show's only genuine movie star after the
death of Cattrall's brother in 2018
Parker expressed sympathy during a red
carpet interview cotrol responded on
Instagram writing your continuous
reaching out is a painful reminder of
how cruel you really were then and now
you are not my friend so I'm writing to
tell you one last time to stop
exploiting our tragedy in order to
restore your nice girl persona she ended
the post with a link to Froelich story
in 1992 Penny Marshall directed a league
of their own about the short life of the
first professional all-female baseball
league well wouldn't you know it as
memorable as Geena Davis was in the
film's lead she wasn't the original pic
for Dottie Hinson that honor went to
Debra Winger who quit the role two weeks
before filming a little bit of a
reputation of going head-to-head with
your co-stars and and kind of mix it up
with them winger who'd already had a
reputation for not getting along with
other cast members apparently he had a
problem with Madonna who both appeared
in the film and provided its theme song
this used to be my playground lead
producer Eliot Abbott told the Baltimore
Sun that winger worried that her
presence would cause a circus atmosphere
it would be interesting to see how
wingers career trajectory might have
changed if she put up with Madonna's
presence in the years since she so
thoroughly disappeared from the
limelight that it inspired rosanna
arquette to make the 2002 documentary
searching for Debra Winger we'll
probably never know exactly what Bill
Murray said on the set of 2000 star
Lee's angels had angered Lucy Liu to the
point that he was replaced by the late
Bernie Mac in its sequel Charlie's
Angels full throttle but the basic gist
is that while filming a scene Murray
said something questioning Liu's acting
talent and Liu responded by throwing
punches at him until the crew pulled
them apart in some versions Murray
simply said you can't act MTV offers an
account that has Murray pointing to Drew
Barrymore Cameron Diaz and finally Lucy
Liu in succession and saying I get why
you're here and you've got talent but
what in the hell are you doing here you
can't act whatever was said Murray and
Liu reportedly didn't get along after
the incident leading Murray to turn down
an appearance in number two okay so
let's get one thing straight
Christian Bale didn't force you and
McGregor to quit mm Samaritan Psycho
they were never cast mates to begin with
what they were however were competitors
that's right bailed pretty much
strong-armed the Star Wars actor until
he yanked his hat right back out of the
ring while good ol Leonardo DiCaprio was
initially attached to the project
he eventually bowed out and Bale was
determined to land the role he even
refused other roles for nine months in
order to keep his schedule open even
though the studio was still looking for
a leading man elsewhere one part of me
wants to take her out and talk to her
and what the other part of him think
putter head would look like on a stick
eventually execs turn to you and
McGregor but he inexplicably gave it a
pass when GQ asked Bale if he could
confirm rumors that it was him who
convinced McGregor to say no he
responded absolutely I phoned a few
people and let them know my commitment
let me tell you I called them all and
told him it was my role
don't touch step away or if you're not
going to step away understand what
you're up against pretty yeah I mean I
guess I'm a pretty sick guy which means
from a certain point of view you could
say Batman use the Jedi mind trick on
obi-wan Kenobi
and that's pretty cool
[Music]